this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles
unlimited access starting at just 2
dollars 99 a month and 30 days for free
if you sign up through the link below
and use the code biographic s' or on
their minutes a hundred years ago
Egyptologist James Henry breasted
described hatshepsut as the first great
woman in history of whom we are informed
this is particularly ironic seeing as
how one or more pharaohs who came after
her tried to have her erased from
history through damnatio memoriae
maybe they hated her maybe they resented
her success or maybe they simply wanted
a return to a tradition thankfully they
did not succeed which means that today
we can bring you the story of hatshepsut
the woman who became a pharaoh
[Music]
Hatshepsut was born circa 1508 BC she
was part of Egypt's 18th dynasty which
was founded by our Moses the first and
became notable for several reasons for
starters it also included other
well-known historical figures such as
Tutankhamun and Nefertiti more
importantly though it was the first
dynasty of the so-called New Kingdom a
period in ancient Egyptian history which
is considered one of its golden ages
some even hail it as the most prosperous
time for the Empire
this is debatable mother's good argue
that the Old Kingdom which was defined
by the construction of the pyramids
represented the true halcyon days of
Egypt but one thing that's for certain
is that after the New Kingdom ended the
Empire experienced steady decline and
would never again reach the same heights
this dynasty is also known as the third
most dynasty because several of the
pharaohs were named that Moses or that
most say whichever you prefer how absurd
herself was the daughter of that Moses
the first stepsister and wife of
phimosis the second and stepmother of
that Moses the third speaking of names
we already gave a brief rundown on the
naming conventions for pharaohs in our -
Tonka Moon video which you can check out
if you haven't seen it already basically
the full royal titles included five
separate names a pharaoh today typically
went by hatshepsut which was part of her
personal name but she was also often
referred to by her throne name of Macari
at Shep sorts is sometimes identified as
the first female pharaoh and this is
really not actually true she is
certainly the first one on whom we have
good information and you can make a
strong case that she was the greatest
female pharaoh but she was probably not
the first unfortunately we cannot say
with accuracy who was the first because
there is a lot of uncertainty
surrounding the rulers of the earliest
dynasties there were plenty of female
regions who ruled as guardians of child
monarchs until they came of age however
as early as the first dynasty it is
possible that queens such as manis Thor
niece Jota may have rules at least for a
short while as pharaohs in their own
right the first one on whom we have
pretty solid evidence is Sabich neferu
after her brother Armand and Hart the
fourth died without
she took the throne and ruled for almost
four years
statutes and inscriptions of Sabich now
fruit depicts her with the full raw
regalia and titles of a pharaoh like her
brother she also did not have any heirs
so her death also brought the end of the
12th dynasty at Shep suits was the
daughter of Pharaoh that Moses the first
and his great royal wife our mo say it
was common for pharaohs to have multiple
wives but only one was the main wife who
had certain authority and perform two
functions we would associate with a
queen normally the heir of the pharaoh
was the son of the great royal wife but
this was not always the case indeed this
was not what we had here but most is the
second succeeded to the throne after his
father's death circa 1493 BC but he was
not the son of our mo say but rather a
secondary wife caught much no fret the
new Pharaoh married his stepsister
hatshepsut when she was only about
twelve years old they only had one child
we know are the daughter Accord never RA
the Pharaohs other child was his heir
that Moses the third whom he had with
his secondary wife yet the reign of that
Moses the second is one full of
questions including how long it actually
lasts it the traditional length which
comes from ancient sources is 13 to 14
years but some modern Egyptologists
argue that it may have been a full
decade shorter assuming the older
version then the Pharaoh would have died
in 1479 BC technically he was succeeded
by his son that Moses the third but the
new king was only two or three years old
so his stepmother the great royal wife
had sepsis ruled as his regions so far
everything went according to protocol
that hatshepsut was expected to cede all
authority whence that Moses came of age
she didn't though instead she took the
power for herself and became a fully
fledged Pharaoh unfortunately we don't
have the complete details of her rise to
the throne we don't know if it was
something gradual as hatshepsut kept
awarding herself more and more authority
or if she took over in one fell swoop we
do know that in the early years of our
Regency she used traditional title such
as King's chief wife or God
wife and was portrayed sitting behind or
to the side of the young pharaoh however
around the seventh year of that Moses's
reign
she began being depicted as the king of
egypt with all the titles and regalia
that came with it what would be nice to
know is how the people of Egypt reacted
to this power play she ruled as Pharaoh
for well over a decade so clearly they
weren't that up in arms about it but
that may also be due to the fact that
she took extra steps to gain their
approval for starters Hatshepsut
established her divine legacy which was
easy to do since she was the daughter of
Moses the first and she also claims that
it was always his will for her to rule
alongside a stepbrother afterwards she
obtained the supports of the high
officials how exactly she did this we
don't know probably with bribes and
promotions but we do know the name of
one man who achieved great status during
her reign his name was Sinan woods and
he was among others the great treasurer
the chief role architect and the chief
steward of the king's daughter because
of his swift rise to power there has
been speculation that he and hatshepsut
might have been lovers but there's no
proof of this his true legacy is the
mortar II temple that he designs and
built thatch sepsis which remains even
today among the most recognizable
examples of ancient Egyptian
architecture moreover there was also the
ceiling decoration of his own tomb which
contains a celestial diagram and
represents one of the most detailed
displays of Egyptian astronomy the last
step in hatshepsut process to secure
power was the most unusual as it had not
been employed by any of the other female
pharaohs except that portrayed herself
as a man there are statues and
inscriptions of her where she clearly is
depicted with a male body and described
using male pronouns she even has the
fake pointy beards that we see on a lot
of Pharaohs that being said this
practice wasn't universal and we also
have statues where hatshepsut is shown
as a woman as well as they're being
inscriptions where she used feminine
titles such as the female Horus or
daughter of rah perhaps once she felt
her position was secure she abandons the
customer
[Music]
now we move on to Shep's its motivation
for power grab many historians believe
she did it purely to satisfy her
ambition in fact when hatshepsut story
was first being unraveled about a
century ago she was portrayed in a very
negative light scholars of that time
accused her of acts of deception and
deviant behavior they called her the
vilest type of usurper and a vain
ambitious and unscrupulous woman they
said that our husbands that moses ii was
a frail and weak ruler whom she easily
pushed around and manipulated while the
scheming Senenmut was her co-conspirator
and lover meanwhile that Moses the third
grub loading his stepmother and took
revenge on her after she died by trying
to erase her name from history it's a
compelling story where hatshepsut
portrays the villain but one that has
fallen out of favor with today's
scholars who consider it based more on
the preconceptions of the time rather
than hot proof while it is possible even
likely that it was hatshepsut desire for
power which determined our actions to
say that she was a deviant ruthless
usurper is tad too far after all if she
was really so cold-blooded she would
have found a way to get rid of her
stepson since he was the biggest threat
to power especially after he came of age
but well she never did she never
threatened or persecuted him the Moses
was allowed to do as he pleased if her
strange as a soldier and then became the
commander of the Egyptian army in fact
some historians a pine that hatshepsut
did exactly the opposite that she took
power during a political crisis to
protect herself and Moses from another
Pretender to the throne from a different
branch of the royal family once she did
it it was a lifetime gig so she couldn't
surrender power even if she wanted to or
perhaps she was telling the truth all
along when she said that her father
wanted her to succeed in as Pharaoh
unlikely yes
impossible no motivations aside let's
talk about hatshepsut actual reign was
actually any good well in fact it was
and historians describe it as a period
of prosperity for Egypt it was also
relatively peaceful there is mention of
some military expeditions but we don't
know any specific details because they
were so poorly documented scholars
applying that had said sir did it more
out of a sense of obligation
that it was her duty to continue the
conquests of our Father the true
triumphs of hatshepsut's reign as
Pharaoh came from trade and construction
according to records she reestablished a
network with one of their former trade
partners during the Middle Kingdom and
mysterious lands known as punt an
ancient inscription says that the
Pharaohs ships returned filled with
ebony ivory myrrh cinnamon wood and the
green gold of EMU aka electrum nowadays
we're not even sure where punt was
exactly best guesses suggest the south
east of Egypt's long the Red Sea coast
over parts of modern countries such as
Somalia Eritrea and Sudan Hatshepsut was
also a prolific builder the age of the
pyramids might have been over but she
wanted to show that Egypt was still
capable of grands constructions she
started off with monuments of the table
of Karnak there she acted the twin
100-foot tall herbalists which at the
time were the tallest in the world she
was clearly a fan of these giant stone
pillars she ordered the construction of
several more throughout her reign the
biggest of them all cracked while it was
being carved and it was simply abandoned
in its quarry and aswan it has since
become known as the unfinished obelisk
and not only is it still there today but
it has provided us with a unique insight
into how ancient Egyptian stone workers
built these monuments of course
Hatshepsut masterpiece was her mortuary
temple the Jessa Jessa rooh Holy of
Holies it has three levels decorated
with reliefs and statues each level had
colonnades which tolls of hatshepsut
triumph the birth colonnade for example
presented her divine creation and how
the god Amun was a true father the punch
colonnades as you might expect detailed
how she once again brought riches from
the lands of punts back to Egypt there
were several temples and chapels
dedicated to the gods there were also
several tombs located in proximity such
as that of senemo to the chief architect
of a mortuary temple for unknown reasons
he was never placed inside his tomb and
we don't know where he is buried now
just when we get into the rest of
today's video if you'd like to learn
more about ancient egypt well I have to
tell you about today's sponsor curiosity
stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclude
originals now if you're enjoying this
one all about engines eat ribs then
you'll love curiosity stream because I
can't just recommend a specific
documentary on ancient Egypt because
they have so many so go over there try
out the free trial just type in ancient
Egypt and so many will come up you'll
just find one that you like I'm sure of
this curiosity stream is available on
many platforms web app Roku Android Xbox
one smart TV iOS chromecast Amazon farms
and Kindle Apple TV and it's available
worldwide gonna limited access starting
at just two dollars 99 a month and for
you guys the first 30 days are
completely free sign up through the link
below
use the code bar graphics during the
signup process to get that it's a great
way to support the show let's get back
to it
as with many pharaohs the story of
hatshepsut has continued into modern
times thanks to archaeologists finding a
tomb however her contemporary tale is a
long and complicated one that stands out
from the rest because it has been
developing for over 200 years
Hatshepsut died in 1458 BC and was
buried in a royal tomb dubbed kV 20
originally alongside her father
formosa's the first the tomb itself is
notable because Egyptologists believe it
may have been the first of its kind
built in the region known today as the
Valley of the Kings the first mention we
have of the tomb in modern times
actually comes to us courtesy of
Napoleon maybe not him personally but
the scientific expedition he led there
in 1799 it was part of his campaign into
Egypt in Syria which mostly consisted of
him fighting the Ottoman and the English
Empire on the military side the campaign
was a flop Napoleon failed to conquer
Syria and while he did capture Egypt he
later had to surrender it in order to
withdraw on the scientific side however
it turned out to be one of the most
significant expeditions in history a
large contingency of 167 engineers and
scientists from all areas of study
traveled to Egypt they mapped the area
and recovered thousands of items a
particular importance was the discovery
of one artifact by a young engineer
named Pierre Francois Bashar an artifact
without which we would have not been
able to understand the language
traditions and history of the Egyptians
and that's the rosetta stone these
discoveries triggered renewed interest
in ancient Egypt back in Europe and more
alas helped establish the field of
Egyptology as far as cave e20 was
concerned the French found it and mapped
it but it was buried under rubble so
they did not explore it in 1817
pioneering Italian Egyptologist Giovanni
Battista belzoni also made note of the
tombs location but like before he did
not have the time resources or
disposition to excavate it by the way
that belzoni was quite a character and
he lived a fascinating life one you can
learn all about on a video we don't know
him a while back so let's get back to
Hatshepsut it wasn't until 1825 then an
attempt was made to excavate her tomb by
British scholar James Burton he only
made it as far as the first
chamber afterwards came German
Egyptologist karl richard lepsius in
1844 who mapped out parts of the tomb
but again failed to make any significant
progress
it wasn't until 1904 that someone
finally managed to clear out all the
debris and completely excavate kV 20 and
then someone was Howard Carter the same
archaeologist who would discover the
tomb of Tutankhamun 18 years later
Carter completely cleaned out the tomb
of all its contents but afterwards came
the hard part of trying to make sense of
what he found there were quite a few
artifacts which inscriptions mentioning
hatshepsut as the king of Upper and
Lower Egypt cementing the idea that she
served as Pharaoh in her own right and
not just as Regents however what puzzled
Egyptologists was the presence of two
sarcophagi but no mummies inside both
had been built for hatshepsut yet
neither one contained any mummies the
mystery of why there were two coffins
was solved relatively easily when
archaeologists translated the
hieroglyphics part of the inscription
said long live the female Horus Shep
sought Canet amoun may she live forever
she made us as her monuments to her
father whom she loved that Moses the
justified basically the first
sarcophagus had been built for
Hatshepsut but then she refurbished it
for her father so that they would be
buried together however that Moses the
first was later removed from the
sarcophagus and placed inside another
tomb kV 38 this was supposed to be a
grandma's Aliyah more befitting someone
of his stature but this tomb was
discovered and completely plundered by
looters well that still left one big
question what happens to hatshepsut her
remains were probably removed alongside
those of her father but where did they
go
over the decades several potential
candidates were put forward Hatshepsut
became similar to Nefertiti another
famous Egyptian queen whose remains have
yet to be found
every time the new female mummy was
discovered there was about the right age
people speculated that it might be the
long-lost Pharaoh one of those
candidates was a nameless mummy
discovered in 1903 also by Howard Carter
in 2 kV 60 this was a modest tomb that
belonged to Citra in women who held the
title of royal wet nurse to hatshepsut
her remains were also located
inside the cribs so this begs the
question of who was the second mummy
Egyptologist Elizabeth Thomas was the
first to speculate in the 1960s that the
unidentified mummy might be hatched
episode back then however the technology
wasn't ready yet to support up offices
it wasn't until last decade that we
finally got some evidence to back up
this idea
besides the mummy archaeologists had
previously recovered other items
belonging to hatshepsut from a mortuary
temple among them was a wooden box with
her name on it which contained a
preserved molar purported to be that of
the Pharaoh
in 2007 forensic orthodontists took the
tooth and compared it to several mummies
believed to be hatshepsut to see if they
matched in deeds the one found in cave
e60 fit the bill exactly prompting many
scholars to proclaim this long last at
Shep suits had been found to strengthen
their argument DNA tests also showed
that the mummy shared genetic
similarities to our mo say Nefertari the
first queen of the 18th dynasty
that's not conclusive but it did show
they were related and therefore the kV
60 mummy who came from a raw bloodline
this proof was enough from an
Egyptologist so though plenty of others
remain skeptical to this day let's
assume like many others did that the
mummy found in kV 60 is indeed
Hatshepsut in that case we can also
start talking about her cause of death
ancient sources are quiet on the subject
as the Pharaoh
simply disappeared from the historical
record although it is generally presumed
that she died in her twenty-second
regnal year if the mummy is hatshepsut
then she wasn't exactly at the peak of
good health shocking I know
the Pharaoh was an overweight
middle-aged woman with arthritis bad
skin bad teeth and she may have suffered
from diabetes and probably died of skin
cancer first of all she may have given
herself cancer by using a cast neogenic
skin treatments in the same place that
archaeologists found the wooden box with
hatshepsut tooth they also recovered a
flask at first they thought it
originally contained perfume but later
they concluded that it was some sort of
lotion used to treat a skin condition
like psoriasis or eczema it contained
traces of harmless ingredients like oils
and fatty acids but also at our residue
that could have caused cancer it's
impossible to say how long the Pharaoh
you
use the lotion for but it is definitely
possible that she inadvertently poisoned
herself to alleviate the symptoms of her
skin disease that could potentially
solve the riddle of hatshepsut death but
there is still the mystery of her
disappearance
by all accounts had shep suit was
condemned damnatio memoriae after a
death that the process where a name and
actions were removed from the historical
record to try and make it look like she
never existed but the question is or why
in this regard scholars have only ideas
and speculations many have pointed the
finger at the obvious suspect stepson
that mostest the third or possibly his
son and successor amenhotep ii or even
both of them the motives were varied we
have no document or artifact to suggest
how fat Moses felt about his stepmother
but he could have resented her for
basically usurping his power when she
was just supposed to rule his regions he
could have also wanted to eliminate her
reign to create a more direct lineage to
his father and grandfather that Moses
the seconds and phimosis the first if
that's the case though the damnatio
memoriae was more likely ordered by
Amenhotep than his father that moses the
third became a great pharaoh in his own
right and his claim to the throne was
unquestionable in facts he was ancient
Egypt's most successful military ruler
and created the largest Egyptian Empire
in history and he is also someone you'll
probably see on this channel in the near
future
i'ma light up the second on the other
hand was not his father's first choice
as successor he was not his firstborn
son nor was he given birth to by that
Moses his great raw wife however the
original heir Prince Arman M hearts and
his mother both died thus allowing
Amenhotep to take the throne the Pharaoh
could have felt that this royal claim
was not as strong as it could be so he
sought to create a direct lineage to the
first rulers of the 18th dynasty and
eliminate outliers by which we mean
except sought or it could be that the
motive was far less personal and it
simply represented a return to tradition
had Shepherds reign even though it was
successful and helped the Empire prosper
went against the norm some argued that
it was a problem exactly because it was
successful this it showed Egyptians that
women could make good pharaohs too and
they couldn't have that could they
whatever the reason might have been and
whoever may have wanted hatshepsut are
raised from the history books the
important thing is the
they did not do a very good job most of
the small artifacts that had our image
or inscriptions were just left alone
even the bigger stuff like statues or
stal I were just smashed up and buried
outside a temple when archaeologists
excavated the area in the 19th and 20th
centuries they were able to recover
enough information to restore hatshepsut
it's name and allow her to once again
take her rightful place as one of the
great Pharaoh's of history so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do smash that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe and do check it off fantastic
sponsor curiosity stream link to below
and thank you for watching
[Music]
you